what i want to do in this video is that
for some triangle we're going to focus
on this larger triangle over here
triangle abc
what i want to do is prove that the
circumcenter of this triangle remember
the circumcenter is the intersection of
its perpendicular bisectors that the
circumcenter for this triangle the
centroid of this triangle the centroid
is the intersection of its medians and
the ortho center of this triangle that's
the intersection of its altitudes all
sit on the same line or that o i right
over here really is a line segment or
that o g
and gi are really just two segments that
make up this larger line segment which
is part of the euler line
and to do that i've set up a medial
triangle right over here triangle fed or
actually i should say triangle def which
is the medial triangle for a
b c and there's already a bunch of
things that we know about medial
triangles and we've proven this in
previous videos one thing we know is
that the medial triangle a d e f d e f
is going to be similar to the larger
triangle the triangle is the medial
triangle of it it is of and that ratio
from the larger triangle to the smaller
triangle is a two to one ratio this is
going to be really important to our
proof when two triangles are similar
with the given ratio that means that if
you take the distance between any two
corresponding parts of the two similar
triangles that ratio will be two to one
now the other relationship that we've
already shown the other relationship
between a medial triangle and the
triangle that is the medial triangle of
is that we've shown that the orthocenter
of the medial triangle the orthocenter
of the medial triangle is the
circumcenter of the larger triangle so
one way to think about it point o we
already mentioned is the circumcenter of
the larger triangle it is also the it is
also the ortho center of the smaller
triangle and we actually wrote it up
here so point o notice it is on this out
it is on this perpendicular bisector
over here and i actually drew a bunch of
other ones in this dark gray color but i
didn't want a cloud i didn't want to
make this diagram too messy but this is
the circumcenter of the larger triangle
and it is also the ortho center of the
smaller triangle of d e f and we
actually use this fact when we wanted to
prove that ortho centers are concurrent
we started with the medial triangle we
said okay let's find its or let's let's
think about where the altitudes
intersect and we said well look all of
these altitudes are actually
perpendicular bisectors for a larger
triangle if we assume that this is the
medial triangle of that larger triangle
so 0.0 and this is going to be important
to our proof it is a circumcenter of
triangle abc but it's the ortho center
of def and we've already talked about
this in previous videos
now in order to prove that o g and i
all sit on the same line or the the same
segment in this case what i'm going to
do is prove
i want to prove
i'm going to prove that triangle f o g
i'm going to prove the triangle f o g
is similar is similar to triangle
c
i g
is similar to triangle
c i g because if i can prove that then
their corresponding angles are going to
be equivalent you could say that this
angle is going to be equal to this angle
over here and so oi would have to be a
transversal because we're going to see
that these two lines over here are
parallel or if the if these two
triangles are similar so remember we're
looking at this triangle right over here
and this triangle over there if they
really are similar then this angle is
going to be equal to that angle which
would mean that they're so these are
really would be vertical angles and so
this really would be a line so let's go
to the actual proof
so maybe i well i won't leave those two
highlighted right there so one thing and
i hinted at this already
we know that this line right over here
we could call this line x c we know this
is perpendicular line a b it is an
altitude and we also know that f y right
over here is perpendicular to a b
it is a perpendicular bisector so they
say they both form the same angle with a
transversal you could view a b as a
transversal so they must be parallel so
we know that f y
f y is parallel to x c
to x c
segment f y is parallel to segment xc
and we could write it like this this
this guy is parallel to that guy there
and that's useful because we know that
alternate interior angles of a
transversal when a transversal
intersects two parallel lines are
congruent so we know
we know that this angle so we know that
fc is a is a line it is a median of this
larger triangle triangle abc so you have
a line intersecting two parallel lines
alternate interior angles are congruent
so that angle is going to be congruent
to that angle so we could say angle
o f g
angle o
f g
is congruent to angle so o f g is
congruent to angle i c g
2 i c g
now the other thing the other thing we
know and this is a property this is a
property of medians is that a median
splits up or i should say the centroid
splits the median into two segments that
have a ratio of two to one or another
way to think about is the centroid is
two thirds along along the median so we
know we've proven this in a previous
video we know that cg
c
g
is equal to two times gf
two times gf and i think you see where
you're going we're going here we have an
angle i've shown you that the ratio of
this side to this side is two to one and
that's just the property of centroids
and medians and now if we can show you
that the that the ratio of this side ci
to fo is two to one then we have two
corresponding sides where the ratio is
two to one and we have the angle in
between this congruent we could use sas
similarity to show that these two
triangles are actually similar so let's
actually think about that
ci is the distance between
ci is the distance between the larger
triangle's point c and its orthocenter
right i is the orthocenter of the larger
triangle well what is fo
well f is a corresponding point to point
c on the medial triangle and we we made
sure that we specified the similarity
with the right
f
f corresponds to point c
so f o is the distance between
f on the smaller medial triangle and the
smaller medial triangles orthocenter so
this is the distance between c and the
ortho center of the larger triangle this
is this is the distance between the
corresponding side of the medial
triangle and its orthocenter so these
this is the same corresponding distance
on the larger triangle and on the medial
triangle and we already know that they
have they're similar with the ratio of
two to one and so the the corresponding
distances between any two points on the
two triangles are going to have the same
ratio
so because of that similarity
because of that similarity we know that
c i
c i is going to be equal to 2
times f o i want to emphasize this c is
the corresponding point to f when we
look at both of these similar triangles
i is the ortho center of the larger
triangle o is the ortho center of the
smaller triangle you're taking a
corresponding point to the ortho center
of the larger triangle corresponding
point of the smaller triangle to the
ortho center of the smaller triangle the
triangles are similar to ratio of two to
one so the ratio of this length to this
length is going to be two to one so
we've shown
we've shown that the ratio of this side
to this side is two to one we've shown
that the ratio of this side
to this side is also two to one and
we've shown that the angle in between
them
are the angle between in between them is
congruent so we have proven by sas
similarity so let me scroll down a
little bit
so by
by s a s similarity
not congruency similarity we've proven
that triangle
f o g is similar to triangle c
i g and so we know corresponding angles
are congruent we know that angle c i g
corresponds to angle f o g
so those are going to be congruent and
we also know that angle cgi
angle cgi let me do some new color
angle cgi corresponds to angle ogf
so they're also going to be congruent so
you can look at it different ways if
this angle and this angle are the same
you can now view o i as a true line as a
transversal of these two parallel lines
so that lets you know it's one line or
you could look at these two over here
say look these two angles are equivalent
so these must be vertical angles and so
this must actually be this actually must
be the same line the angle that this is
approaching this this median right over
here is the same angle that it's leaving
so these are all these are definitely on
the same line so it's a very simple
proof once again for a very profound
idea that the orthocenter the centroid
and the median of any triangle all sit
on this magical euler's line